retour au premier titre de journal je
vous le disais tout à l'heure l'évasion
ce matin à la prison de la santé
c'est comme au cinéma c'est comme les
films américains de préférence mais la
fiction vous allez le voir dépasse la
réalité en tout cas elle est aussi
spectaculaire ce matin vers 11 heures à
la prison de la santé un homme s'est
évadé il s'appelle michel vaujour il a
choisi un moyen étonnant sans doute le
plus faire sans doute pas le plus facile
un hélicoptère est venu le chercher
pendant la promenade alors tout de suite
roland sicard à la prison de la santé
l'opération avait été préparée dans le
plus pur style des superproductions
américaines hélicoptère aux plaques
maquiller pilotes ayant coupé toutes les
communications avec la police minutage
précis 10h ce matin la santé un appareil
blanc de type alouette emprunter le
matin même à saint cyr l'école
s'installe en stationnaire au dessus des
toits de la prison mais je lui pardonne
serais toi quand enfin home avec roland
rouge survêtement bleu est monté sur le
toit il a rampé sur le sol anglais du
toit seul fignon celui derrière 400 m à
notre homme qui était apparemment torse
nu ou avec
paulo
comme avec le tee-shirt rouge avait
monté un hélicoptère quelqu'un l'a aidé
intérieure semble les pas mal de
difficultés l'autre qui était derrière
n'a pas eu le temps de monter
l'hélicoptère est reparti en direction
du sud
si vous n'avez pas entendu tu veux pas
de coups de feu pas d'avertissement
streums et comme père j'ai beaucoup de
bruit quand est ce que l'alerté a été
donnée
ben il n'y a pas eu la lettre mais
j'aurai ensuite on avait les policiers
qui prenant tous les sens mais c'est
pride alerte on n'a pas entendu de
sirène à rien du tout le détenu qui a
réussi à s'évader était loin d'être un
inconnu des services de police michel
vaujour purgeait à la santé une peine de
18 ans de réclusion criminelle pour
tentative d'homicide volontaire et vol à
main armée l'hélicoptère a été localisée
par la police dans le 14e arrondissement
sur le terrain de football de la cité
universitaire ses occupants
bien entendu avait disparu